das ganze rum
das jägerbataillon 25 ist der einzige
verband des österreichischen
bundesheeres dass das bordeauxrote
paredes trägt und wir tragen das barett
mit stolz das bedeutet für uns wir
fassen das paket nicht nur aus sondern
es muss auch leistungen erbracht werden
um dieses barrett zu tragen
dies passiert in form des barrett
matches hier befinden wir uns am
startpunkt des partners vor der
hollenburg im kärntner rosen bei
kabarettist einmarsch der seit beginn
der kader kompanie im bataillon
durchgeführt wird
unabhängig vom dienstgrad ist dieser
marsch zu absolvieren
damit man das rote barette fragen dar
[Musik]
kurzum wieskötter
so sind ua geben der der wirtschaft
und dass die letzte mission der 64
[Musik]
ich bin der logistiker versicherten 25
seit einem jahr neu im verband und es
muss sich jeder das barett verdienen
heute ist meine chance dazu los geht's
[Musik]
warum nehmen
si
[Musik]
es werden als ca 19 kilometer zurücklegt
haben gerade die flussüberquerung
gemacht die flussüberquerung hass
erzeugt verpacken durchschwimmen
die auspackt weitermarschieren seine
haltung
es geht noch alles ziemlich gut wir
haben noch gut mehr als ein viertel vor
also mehr als drei viertel für uns
und ich schätze dass wenn wir doch gut
hingegen in der tat
[Musik]
was ist wenn es da nicht auch den
kilometerlangen ist eine station
übersetzen
das heißt urlaub haben und jetzt
eigentlich relativ guter wein
aufgeteilt auf deine gruppen gekommen
[Musik]
weil
sendung
[Musik]
er werde so schnell wie sich vorkommen
wie zu nehmen wie es ist mit einer von
beiden seiten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir sind gerade beim schneiden hier
vielleicht zähle nach wie mich die ganze
länge für mich schon seit sieben stunden
[Musik]
ja
dafür
[Musik]
dubai
ja diese gebiete reaktor isar 1
[Musik]
berlin
mehr
[Applaus]
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen am freund werk zur
grillstation
sie haben rufen 12 erkannt sondern
beleuchtet arrangiert davon mit namen
als verstorbene fünften rang halten ist
durchhaltevermögen und
durchsetzungsvermögen zu zeigen auch
wenn die situation schwer wenn man sich
überwindet man vielleicht im moment ist
etwas angst hat aber sie trotzdem darf
einfach durchbeißen unter durchschlägt
mehr oder weniger und treue sich so
gegenüber den kameraden so wir sind alle
im selben boot und meine kameraden für
mich sind wir in eine zweite familie
catala schon
mutig treu
[Musik]
auch kabarett verleihung noch dass ein
schwitzender barrett der stadt ja das
ist noch nicht vorbei
[Musik]
hatte
[Applaus]
[Musik]
nur ins ziel kommen wollen wir versuchen
aber gesundheitlich fünf kilometer vor
schluss abbrechen müssen
durch gewesen ein zweiter versuch übers
tor
und jetzt bin ich besser oder bauträger
gemäß dem leitspruch mut tapferkeit und
treue haben wir heute bei megawatt am 25
den barrett macht geführt
ich freute es besonders dass ich 35
soldatinnen und soldaten das rote
fahrrad verleihen dürfte
wenn auch du teil der 25er gemeinschaft
werden willst dann informiere ich im
internet
[Musik]